hallo leute ihr seid eure mal waren sie
kamen zu einem neuen adventskalender
ausparken video es ist nur drei tage ja
soll ich das letzte video hochgeladen
haben daran merkt ihr ich meins die
angst es geht jetzt wieder los als
kleiner werden ausgepackt der heutige
adventskalender ist der song und
longines und ländern liegen wie ihr es
auch immer aussprechen wollte der
anscheinend vegan nachhaltig
zusammengestellt wurde und sogar hand
verpackt packen wir ihnen mal auf es
gibt schon mal das erste geschenk eine
sehr geiler handcreme ohne gedöns ich
bin tatsächlich über so eine handcreme
auf chandler gene und lenin und lenzin
und ländlich ich werde sehen und lernen
sagen es tut mir leid falls es an das
land ich bin über diese handcreme auf
schiene und len gekommen weil sie in
einem adventskalender drin war und die
ist super geil supergeil habt ihr immer
noch und ich benutze die aber auch echt
gerne noch ein gratis geschenk ein
schlankes auch noch dazu ist ja sehr
nett
ich wollte gerade sehr vorsichtig mit
dem karton sein weil ich dieses jahr
natürlich auch wieder adventskalender
verlosen werde dich denn selbst zusammen
gepackt habe also falls ihr den inhalt
dieser adventskalender gewinnen wollt
müsst ihr auf instagram folgen da hatte
ich auch mal wanne und dann muss ich
dann irgendwann die gewinnspiele das
design des absolut atemberaubend schön
und was ich letztes mal vergessen hab
dieses videos nicht gesponsert und jetzt
alle dieses videos nicht geschafft ich
habe mir das selber gekauft das ist
meine ehrliche meinung ist es einfach
eine rezension von einem adventskalender
und jetzt machen wir das haus auf ich
verstehe nicht wie man diesen
adventskalender kommt
öffnen wir dich mal
das ist ein für zauber der
adventskalender schaut euch diese selbst
verpackten päckchen an halli hallo
[Applaus]
du hast du kannst du dein kleines
häuschen
und das sieht super schön aus doch erst
seit das einzige was ich nicht ganz
verstehen es halt wirklich diese griff
funktion hier was ich total cool finde
ist dass die produkte von jean und
länder im supermarkt zu kaufen sind aber
trotzdem
während adventskalender sich so voller
homemade irgendwie so anfühle richtig
geil was hast du gekostet 59 99 hab ich
bezahlt die produkte sollen im wert von
mehr als 115 euro seien also wird sich
100 prozent lohn produkte in
originalgröße keine proben oder heiße
grüßen ich werde ihn ausgeben müssen so
viele tolle geschenke wir fangen an mit
türchen nummer eins
ein türchen nummer eins ist ein shampoo
drin dieses shampoo ist mit rosmarin
ginger also groß marin und ingwer
getrocknet sprödes klasse ist a geeignet
ein freundliches komplex aus
pflanzlichen
wenn düssel neuer dusche steht sorge das
sieht einfach gut aus
absolut absolut tipptopp supercool
megageil zwischen über zwei
habe vielleicht einen kurzen moment das
ist gleich geld vielleicht ist das
hygiene hand geht
thema handgeld so zum desinfizieren
macht ja gerade absolut sinn und sollte
man benutzen manche hand griechen aber
so komisch zum beispiel dass bei rewe
ich finde das riecht so widerlich ich
kann das nicht ab die schon mal in den
reben hat dieses desinfektions zeit
benutzt katastrophal und falls ihr es
wollt euch dieser schreckliche hand
gehen duft bei rewe erinnert würde
schreibt 10 kommentare weil ich komme da
nicht drauf aber ich weiß das erinnert
mich an so etwas also das hier ist so
ist okay machen wir mal weiter mit
erschien und landauer werbesendung und
türchen nummer drei
tagescreme das produktdesign von jean
und dann ist einfach wirklich sehr sehr
schön für dich also optisch macht immer
bisher nicht so wie meine fingernägel
ich könnte nagellackentferner benutzen
ich bin usman als rezept für eine
ewigkeit hätte meine finger den gesehen
wieder halbwegs mensch nicht aus und es
geht weiter mit der tages grebe anti
aging tagescreme die sehr reichhaltig
ist und die falten
sondern sagen die produkte richten
einfach gut angenehmer creme duft
kirchen immer bier
kein gene und produkt eine schokolade
von einer party er sich super gerne für
die stadtwerbung
white lukas christ ist eine sehr sehr
leckere schokolade
das finde ich ja richtig cool dass sie
ja nicht nur ihre eigenen produkte rein
machen sondern auch passende praktisch
so lecker
türchen nummer fünf im gleichen design
wie das shampoo eine handseife leute
stellt euch mal vor ihr habt gäste im
badezimmer und dann steht also eine
handseife also ich mag es natürlich wenn
es wirklich diese frauen apotheken glas
ist das ist halt plastik aber das sieht
auch schon echt nicht schön aus und es
riecht auch nach rosmarin und ingwer
total klassischer schöner duft finde ich
also ganz ganz angenehm und sehr
erwachsen und hochwertig richtig wie wir
haben einen blick wieder eingekriegt wir
haben einen brief krieg ich frage mich
nur von
william handy scott scott dass da ein
soziales projekt drin ist richtig dass
von dem advent zum adventskalender
kannte das in den umschlägen dann halt
soziale projekte drin waren aber wir
haben hier fünf euro gutschein für einen
einkauf im flagship store oder auf
schienen mittelpunkt nikolaus ja gut 5
euro gutschein ist schon in ordnung also
ja ist okay türchen nummer 7 was für
eine tolle hand strem verwirklichen
nummer fünf was wird es sein ihr seht
zuerst
die haben ja mittlerweile jedes produkt
zahnpasta okay wir müssen die zähne
putzen damit wir müssen einfach
bisschen wachs mäßig sieht sie auch
riechen tut sie gut
geschmeckt die lecker geschmeckt wie ein
kaugummi aber wie so ein richtig
leckeres kaugummi nicht zuschauer voll
süß test bestanden titel nummer acht und
irgendwie da was groß ist und einen
großen sack
natürlich darf der condition auch nicht
viel wenn man heute ist jetzt richtig
gut weil der mann ist meine
lieblingszahl hier was er wert ist das
eincremen der gala geschmeidig wie nokia
das ist so deren handcreme ich meine im
winter kann man nicht genug handcreme
haben das stück schon da habe ich jetzt
nach rosen extrakt drin die mit
rosenduft die mache ich jetzt auf die
die ich vorher geschenkt bekommen hat im
paket die packe ich in die verlosung box
gehe
ich mal keine rosen dürft also die
rechtlich in ordnung aber nicht rigoros
irgendwie ich mag das nicht aber die
handcreme sind gut also dran hat echt
ein schönes gefühl danach weiter geht es
mit brief nummer c
gerade das hier so gesehen und dachte
mir was wir das denn für ein gutschein-
sein eine postkarte doch es ist eine
hübsche postkarte ich glaube aber da hat
noch was gehen können ich verschicke die
auf jeden fall klar tüchern
jetzt gibt's ein riesenpaket ich liebe
aber diese verpackung weil es aussieht
als ob es mein freund eingepackt hätte
also diesen rendant überall tesa bahn
macht hauptsache ist hält genauso sieht
es bei meinen freunden im 18 ihr habt
ihr schon mal so hatten wir die ich kann
mich nicht erinnern in irgendeinem
stimmt das wollte ich sie mag über den
alpakas drauf das sind chips aus
kochbanane mit paprikapulver waren
richtig gut drauf hier habt ihr eure
banane
sehr sehr lecker nummer 12
j maria and the holy spirit dann hast du
so eine maria darunter übrigens mein
zweiter name ist maria und dann
alkoholfreier ab herrn spritzt
hergestellt für sheen und len gmbh unser
abgespritzt mach dich nicht du dich
sondern happy allein die farben macht
gute laune und er schmeckt genauso nach
sommertag wie du es liebst er gut im
dezember werde ich meine grenze kalender
auspacke und genauer zu sein das zwölfte
türchen wo sie jetzt nicht mich fühlen
wie in einem schönen sommertag aber das
und ich auf jeden fall ausprobieren
er schmeckt wie ein alkoholfreier
abgespritzt sehr lecker können bisschen
kälter sein dieser adventskalender ist
ein sehr große anwärter für sehr geil
adventskalender wenn die jetzt nicht
mehr verpacken ist sehr geil
adventskalender türchen nummer 13
uhr ist riesig die flasche seht ihr das
begrüßt die ist halo reichhaltige creme
öl dusche nicht sehr gut absolut
fantastisch ich freue mich drauf ist zu
benutzen es ist mit hafer milch und
kokosöl zeit so ganz ob morgens in ein
cafe man macht es nicht es war nur ein
witz aber es war ein genauso flacher
witz wie türchen nummer 14
eine glättende maske mit hohn und hose
nummer
5 c ist reich
ich sag mal so eine frage aber jetzt
hättet ihr euch kein langweiliges design
dafür ausdenken können irgendwie
zeichnung wochen wäre auch cool gewesen
und vielleicht ist logo dann ein
bisschen kleiner an der ecke und dafür
ein großer koch gleich ein großer wochen
mit einer weihnachtsmütze das wäre auch
cool gewesen dass hier wird jetzt mein
pfandflaschen beute nach diesem
wunderschönen heute machen wir weiter
mit nummer 16
das habe ich schon ich fand das auch
eigentlich glaube ich ganz gut ich bin
mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher es ist eine
liefen aufbaus parcours für struktur
geschädigtes haar mit keratin das macht
man sich das massaker nach dem duschen
drauf und anscheinend sind an die haare
weicher da ich diese flasche schon habe
packe ich sie euch natürlich in die
verlosung
[Musik]
das ist es eine deo creme unsere bio deo
creme verwöhnt die achsel haut mit
kokosöl und caro vacano baraks kanada
wachs stammt von der brasilianischen
kanada palme deren blätter sind
beidseitig mit dem pflanzen wachs
beschichtet um sie vor verdunstung zu
schützen nach dem trocknen der blätter
löst sich der großteil des wracks sich
bereits von selbst der rest fertig
schaden klopfen und bürsten gewonnen
wären ätherische öle und sicherlich
frisch doch
es liegt wirklich noch orangene ja ein
festes deo das ist ganz weich
guckt immer ganz kurz weg
ich weiß nicht was ich dazu sagen soll
ich finde den dürfen aber echt nicht so
schlecht aber ich glaube dass er sich
unter den arm ganz schön gut macht wir
machen wir jetzt weiter türchen nummer
ich liebe diese verpackung wisst ihr wie
sich das anfühlt als ob man jeden morgen
ein richtiges geschenk aufmachen kann
also dass für ihn auch machen es auch
schon richtig geil eigentlich
don't judge me es ist ja ja dunkle hose
eine dunkle hose darüber habe ich gerade
gefreut zum glück und soße natürlich ein
veganer dunkle konsum gar nicht gesagt
wenn ich ein bisschen random dass in
diesem kalender der braune soße drin ist
allerdings ist es ja ein
weihnachtskalender und was braucht man
zur weihnachtszeit am 18 dezember
natürlich eine soße ich feiere total
überrascht türchen nummer 19
bodylotion für normale bis trockener
haut mit rosmarin und inga dorf
einfach stimmt die handcreme die ich
damals von den gehabt hatte auch groß
marin ginger und der freund von meiner
freundin sagte mal es riecht nach oma
also falls ihr nach oben richten wollte
rosmarin ginger türchen nummer 20 eine
nachtcreme aha jetzt haben wir noch eine
nachtcreme wir haben zum letzten mal
einen prüfbericht wir haben einen
begriff wie haben einen bild geprägt ich
frag mich nur von
wem mit jedem verkauften adventskalender
habe ich einen baum gepflanzt
türchen nummer 22 länder
fußcreme ist es nichts worüber man
lachen muss fußcreme uns ganz normal
absolut cool und fußcreme halt unser vor
letztes türchen nummer 23 ein tag vor
heiligabend man ist schon komplett in
weihnachtsstimmung und lang macht man
ein kirchen auf und man findet footloose
bio mango fruchtgummi ist natürlich
vegan ist natürlich wird aber ehrlich
gesagt auch danach aus schmeckt wie
pürierter fruchtsaft zusammengequetscht
in ein herzchen
ist okay okay ist nicht mein geschmack
aber nachdem wir dann am 23 eurosuper
leckeren mango fruchtgummis gegessen
habt kommt der tag heiligabend ihr habt
schon diesen adventskalender einen monat
lang aufgemacht 23 tage voller fun fun
fun heute zeitig abend ihr freut euch
drauf mit eurer familie zusammen zu sein
oder mit eurem partner wenn ihr eure
familie hast du dir und dann steht ihr
vor der 24
es kann gar nicht besser vertikal
ein glas glas wie ich japan gesagt habe
organist ist was ist das
bios superform ich liebe es jetzt schon
um hülle dich mit der entspannenden
duftkomposition aus lavendel orange die
beruhigende atmosphäre sorgt für einen
erholsamen und tiefen schlaf aber wo
spare ich mir das drauf
verkauft
ja es riecht mehr nach orange als nach
lavendel
machten spritze auch euer kopfkissen
machten spritzer auf eure armbeuge hier
hin wo auch immer ich liebe es mit einem
schönen aroma schlafen zu gehen oder
mich einfach so zu entspannen wenn ich
zum beispiel meditieren möchte oder ein
entspannendes yoga mache sowie yoga
sprich mehr irgendwas hin spricht was an
den raum an die gardinen oder so und
dieser duft gibt mir dann einfach so
schönes warmes gefühl im herzen deswegen
finde ich auch tatsächlich ist es ein
perfektes 24 türchen dieser kalender hat
es geschafft okay so war es ja eine rein
machen ist in ordnung ist jetzt nicht
das aller tollste jetzt so aber wenn man
dann so mutig ist und eine braune soße
in seinen kalender packt der eigentlich
kosmetika und veganes next beinhaltet er
hat einfach nur meinen respekt verdienen
gehen ja an den kalender schnappt euch
den wenn ihr jemanden kennt der song und
long produkten und produkte die einen
lieben produkte markt dann besorgt
dieser person solvenz kalender oder euch
selber ihr wisst jetzt aber leider was
alles drin ist anscheinend spart man
auch ein bisschen 115 ist der warenwert
gut wenn man so waren wie diesen beutel
mit cds wahrscheinlich der warenwert 115
euro also man kriegt bestimmt was für
sein geld das einzige was man sagen kann
dass 80 euro sind ein stabiler preis das
kann sich jeder leisten und vor allem
wenn man sich das leistet dann erwartet
man auch wirklich viel aber ich finde
hier bekommt man auch was für seine
vorstellung und der fakt dass das so
seeber hand verpackt ist was macht schon
was her das ist das ist total süß und
persönlich und wirkt irgendwie
hochwertiger und man bekommt eine tolle
karton box die aus wien haus also wenn
deswegen kauft und isst und damit noch
mal ne dieses video ist nicht gesprochen
sein das ist meine persönliche meinung
und die fällt sehr positiv aus und jetzt
schaltet ab wir sehen uns beim nächsten
update länder video was wahrscheinlich
in wieder vier tagen sein wird es dann